Reports that Bam Margera was hospitalized in
December didn't explain just how close to death
the "Jackass" star came. But now the daredevil
is giving the full story in his own words.
To usher in the new millennium in grand fashion,
MTV debuted a show in October 2000 that remains
as culturally relevant and hilarious as ever:
"Jackass." If you're somehow unfamiliar with
the series, it featured a group of stuntmen
and old friends doing pranks to each other
and attempting wild stunts. To say it
became a hit would be an understatement
Some of the original stars of the show, including
Johnny Knoxville and Steve-O, have stayed in the
public eye and kept the legacy of "Jackass" alive.
But that hasn't been true for the entirety of the
original crew. For one, there's Bam Margera,
who has lived a roller coaster life since the
now-iconic MTV series first gained prominence.
Margera has found himself in some terrifying
and rather unsavory situations, including
drama with some of his "Jackass" co-stars,
Knoxville among them. Nevertheless, he's
managed to power through and live to tell
his story all these years later. But Margera
revealed he recently came very close to death.
On January 5, 2023, Margera
stopped by the "Steve-O's Wild
Ride!" podcast to commemorate the end of his
conservatorship. Before he could get to that,
though, he had a scary story from
the previous month to share with
listeners. Right out of the gate, he
shared the news of his own "death."
"I basically was pronounced dead
on Elvis' birthday, December 8."
Margera didn't realize it, but he'd been
dealing with an extreme case of COVID-19.
He added that his body started shutting down
and he had four seizures, each of which lasted
between 10 and 20 minutes. The fourth was so
bad that he says he nearly bit off his tongue.
Margera's tongue became swollen and began
bleeding. Margera then swallowed the blood,
which, in turn, resulted in him contracting
pneumonia. Worse yet, on his way to the hospital,
he went into a fifth seizure. With his
swollen tongue, he couldn't breathe.
When he finally came into the hospital, he
thought he'd only been there for a few hours,
but he couldn't have been more wrong. Shortly
after waking up, he remembered being told,
"Like, 'Dude, you've been here for nearly
a week. We tried to take the tube out,
but you weren't breathing on your own."
Thankfully, eight days after
being admitted to the hospital,
Margera made a full recovery and was
released. News outlets picked up on the
story almost immediately. Steve-O mentioned
that after hearing about it on the news and
seeing Margera on a ventilator, he assumed
the worst was right around the corner.
"I'm just thinking, 'Oh my God, this is it.'"
While Margera was in the hospital, Steve-O
joked that if his friend didn't make it through,
that would throw a serious wrench
into his tour plans. Some fans loved
the "Jackass"-style gallows humor; others didn't.
Steve-O made sure to clarify that Margera's
recovery was the top priority. Margera chimed in
with a laugh and compared his newly raspy voice,
thanks to the breathing tube, to that of Steve-O.
Margera doesn't remember much of what happened
to him prior to waking up in the hospital,
saying that he essentially blacked out until
he opened his eyes in the hospital bed. It's
safe to assume he didn't miss a whole
lot throughout his lengthy hospital stay.
As if the past few years haven't shown it already,
COVID-19 is no joke and is more than
capable of killing at a moment's notice.
It's good to hear that Bam Margera was
able to recover from the deadly disease.